[Music]
welcome back to CBS this morning there
is some promising news in the race for a
corona virus vaccine two companies
Pfizer and its German partner by on tech
reported encouraging signs in very early
clinical trials for a possible vaccine a
small study on 45 patients triggered
stronger immune responses in recipients
more than fifteen different possible
vaccines are now being tested on people
worldwide dr. David agus joins us with
the latest on this global effort good to
see you dr. Avis listen you've got the
best doctors the best researchers
working on this we are so craving good
positive news do you have it this
morning based on the results from those
two companies yeah you know science is
gonna win they will win against this
virus and what they showed in this study
is that when they administer the virus
they got a good immune response you know
when I do a cancer trial my goal is to
shrink the cancer when you give a
vaccine the goal is to get a good immune
response and they were able to see
anybody levels that were almost twice
that seen in people who had naturally
got the virus so that's very encouraging
they didn't talk about the t-cell part
of the virus remember the t-cells are
also very important but this is a big
step forward this is what they hope for
but there are reports that some people
in the trial did experience fevers and
other symptoms is that normal well
you're gonna give me a weird look Gail
but yes this is good you know if I give
a vaccine and a patient has a sore arm
or has a fever I'm curing or I have
tears in my eyes because I know it is
working and so that's part of the immune
response you know what they do here in
this case is they give RNA the
instructions for the spike protein of
Koba 19 and then your body's cells make
it and you make an immune response
against that and that protects you from
the virus so this is a new kind of
vaccine very encouraging and exciting
that we're moving forward
encouraging exciting is the words we
like to hear and I just heard you say
science will win and you know the
question to that David is win Dave
when will science win you know the
trials are ongoing
Oxford University is the lead in the
trials now their phase three study
started already in Brazil and the two
three in the United Kingdom and the
results look encouraging this is a
vaccine that had been tried for a decade
in SARS so we know it's safe and they
just plopped in the portion fork Ovid 19
so my hope is we have the data over the
next six weeks or so and we will have a
vaccine in the fall I am very optimistic
we're going to have a vaccine in the
fall and hopefully more than one
candidate oh boy we could use good news
about this story thank you very much
David egg is always good to see you in
California